vous savez pas d'un pouce et monsieur je
suis dit m vertus vela passage normand
position initiale est loyal à surmonter
bien des pires oui ça vient des données
par les fans déchaînés d'un monsieur
desmarest et de la tournée le grand
examen respecte des jeunes ont accepté
pour canaliser l'air dans le magasin
garder monsieur mais monsieur je
comprends votre problème moi je gère
c'est de la discrimination comment il
fait pour faire ses visiteurs scène elle
accepte je ne voudrais pas loin - et
c'est lui placer ses courses
monsieur porter plainte je vous donne
mon ombre le magasin je ne peux pas le
second intervint alors vous êtes dans ce
cas là non je ne sortirai pas mais vous
ne savez pas vous cher monsieur je vous
le dis on avait monsieur moi je vous dis
aux divas sentir même si il va sortire
jour en décompte l'agressivité vous avez
monsieur il va sortir le chasser des
monstres et cie indiquaient que blatter
[Musique]
les principales difficultés en
accessibilité aujourd'hui c'est encore
une méconnaissance de certaines
personnes notamment de financer
l'établissement qui ne connaissent pas
la réglementation sur les chiens guides
et cette réglementation date maintenant
de plus de 30 ans et à l'autorisent le
chien guide est allé partout avec son
maître l'accompagné partout donc ça
c'est encore une petite difficulté
quelques fois où des personnes quand on
voyait on voit un chien arrivée dans un
établissement où il ya de la nourriture
et cetera c'est souvent les problèmes
d'hygiène qui sont évoqués mais bon la
loi est très claire maintenant on peut
pas interdire l'accès du chantier il ya
des noms qui viennent
je trouve quand tous les problèmes ici
est dénommée alors choses certains
problèmes
quelqu'un avec des béquilles ou avec
mieux comme ça fait un peu trop lent il
va remplacer un chien qui était gérée a
beau être champion j'aime bien le
morisien jeunes enfants a créé avec se
cherche vers l'hôpital c'est parti c'est
vraiment temps que claude est en tout
cas c'est bien en anglais ben laden
raison entièrement la boucherie et de
l'hygiène n'accepte pas les chiens
non certainement pas alors fait part
fait que nous avons appelé la plage on
va bien sortir quand vous allez je
sortirai pas appelle la police ne
sortira pas alors qu'ils te star tiré
par le cieux suis partie civile c'est la
dissémination là mais vous renverser le
fauteuil roulant d'un handicapé vous
renversez fauteuil roulant d'un handicap
mais il est mal voyants mais les malvois
fait comment pour faire ses courses et
c'est de la discrimination pure et dure
[Musique]